make no mistake Google got obliterated
by Microsoft's blitzk attack in the
great AI war of 2023 GPT 4 captured the
Zeitgeist of the artificial intelligence
age we just entered and things got so
bad for Google that people unironically
started using Bing but the war is just
getting started and just yesterday
Google Unleashed its highly anticipated
Gemini model that beats GPT 4 on nearly
every Benchmark it is December 7th 2023
and you're watching the code report
Gemini first became known to the public
earlier this year at google.io when
Sundar explained it like this you've
been applying AI to make AI rigorously
tested AI with AI Gemini is a multimodal
large language model that will replace
Lambda and palm 2 like gp4 it's
multimodal which means it's not only
trained on text but also sound images
and video Google's demo is absolutely
insane it can recognize what's going on
in a video feed and respond in real time
like this guy draws a duck then the AI
tells him it's a duck it is a duck like
holy and it can do that in multiple
languages y what's really crazy though
is that it can keep track of things in
an ongoing video feed like it plays the
game of find the ball under the cup and
even after the cups are scrambled up it
still knows where the ball is and it can
even do connect the dots which makes my
5-year-old obsolete it also does
multimodal outputs like it can generate
images on the Fly Like Sable diffusion
and can even generate music based on a
prompt and not just text to audio but
image to audio how about some 8s hair
metal it's an anything to anything model
it's also good at logic and spatial
reasoning using these two pictures it's
able to tell you which car will go
faster based on the aerodynamics of the
vehicle in the future a civil engineer
will be able to just take a picture of
some land then the AI can instantly
generate some blueprints for a bridge so
software Engineers aren't the only type
of Engineers becoming obsolete although
I do of course have some more bad news
for programmers Google also unveiled
Alpha code 2 which performs better than
90% of competitive programmers and we're
talking about programmers solving highly
complex abstract problems like you might
find on code Force's competitions like
any good programmer Alpha code 2 can
break down problems into smaller
problems s using techniques like dynamic
programming now all these demos look
really amazing at first glance but is
this all just a marketing slide of hand
from Google well currently Gemini comes
in three sizes tall Grande and ventti
the smallest version is designed to be
embedded on devices like Android phones
while the pro version is your more
general purpose model while Ultra is
like the Magnum XL of the Gemini family
and the one that's blowing everybody's
Minds if you're in the United States you
can actually use Gemini right now in The
Bard chatbot however it's using Gemini
Pro the mid-range version Bard is way
better than was 6 months ago and it's
still extremely fast but after using it
for a few minutes it's pretty obvious
that it's not quite as good as GPT 4 Pro
but gp4 is nervous about Gemini Ultra
when I asked about it it started
throwing mad shade at itself and then
before it finished Sam Alman pulled a
plug giving me this network error when
it comes to benchmarks Gemini Pro
underperforms GPT 4 in most situations
but Gemini Ultra outperforms it on
almost every single category most
notably it's the first model ever to
outperform human experts on massive
multitask language understanding which
is typically a multiple choice test over
a wide array of subjects kind of like
the SATs but for AI what's hella
surprising though is that Gemini Ultra
underperforms GPT 4 on the hell swag
Benchmark it's designed to evaluate
Common Sense natural language by having
the AI finish a sentence that's often
vague and ambiguous for example a man
watches a fireship video and afterwards
feels blank it's a job that's really
easy for humans to do and a very
important Benchmark because when an AI
can't do this well it doesn't feel very
human-like in GPT 4 I can write a vague
prompt with typos and somehow it almost
always seems to know what I'm talking
about the fact that gp4 is doing so much
better on H swag is hella concerning to
say the least but another interesting
thing to know from the technical paper
is how they train this Beast they use
their newly unveiled version 5 tensor
processing units which are deployed in
super PODS of 4,096 chips each super pod
has a dedicated Optical switch which
allows data to transfer quickly between
the pods to train in parallel then they
can dynamically reconfigure into 3D
tourist topologies in other words they
can shape shift into Donuts to reduce
the latency between ships and the scale
of Gemini Ultra is so large that they
had to communicate between multiple data
centers the paper also describes the
training data set which basically
includes everything you can find on the
internet including web pages and YouTube
videos as well as scientific papers and
books they filter it for Quality then
use reinforcement learning through human
feedback to fine-tune the quality and
avoid hallucinations overall Gemini
looks amazing on paper but prepare to be
disappointed the Nano and Pro Models
will be available on Google Cloud on
December 13th but the Gemini ultr Pro
Max won't be available until next year
until additional safety tests are done
and it reaches 100% on the hell woke
Benchmark this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one